all right today we're talking about an
app that is taking off that I think
might be the next Tik Tok it's a Chinese
app that you've probably never heard of
uh Sam got all the numbers behind a cold
plunge business that's doing over
hundred million doll a years including
their ad numbers which is rare you
almost never get to see that and lastly
we talk about lessons that we learned
from Jess ma a Founder who has built a
business up to $900 million and she
shared one or two golden little nuggets
that we wanted to talk about enjoy this
[Music]
episode
all right let me give you an update on
something so we had you know I take a
lot of pride in the fact that we've had
some people on here right before their
like Fame Arc really took off we had
Brian Johnson on here uh you said that
he mentioned like yeah you guys are one
of my first people another one Andrew
humman we talked to Andrew humman I
remember we talked to him and I think he
was like in this hallway in Stanford or
something like doing an interview with
us and after the pod or during the Pod I
told him that like cold plunging is
interesting to me and after the Pod he
goes hey I want to send you a cold
plunge and I was like that's very kind
of you I I would love that and so he
introduced me to this guy named Ryan
Ryan Dewey Ryan sent me a cold plune and
the company now it's it's uh what's the
URL actually is it I don't even know
what is it plunge. comom plunge. comom
it's just called plunge um he sent me
this thing and I started using it and I
loved it and I dug it and by the way
this also sounds like an ad this is not
an ad I have nothing to do with these
guys um but but Ryan I will take a free
pledge I said no earlier I Chang my mind
did you say no when he offered you one I
said no I said no the first time that's
crazy and uh I was wrong I'm I'm man
enough to admit it I was wrong I would
like a plunge thank you yeah they're
awesome but here's the deal when he was
selling them at the time I think they
were like $3,500 now I think they're
like $5,500 and I didn't know if I liked
doing it so I was like yeah I'll take
one that because that's a lot of money
to spend just for to test something out
and so I got an update on these guys I
think they only launched in 2020 and in
preparation for this podt I just went
and talked to him and got a bunch of
numbers this year they're so here listen
to their revenue in 2020 so the way it
started is Ryan and his partner Michael
they each separately owned um brick and
Mort bus businesses one of them Ryan
owned this thing called a float therapy
uh Center or I don't know float tank
yeah it's like you go it's like a I I
used to call it a deprivation T I used
to do it in San Francisco every once in
a while you like sit in this like
tanning bed that's filled with salt
water you basic float and it's
completely dark and no noise and you
feel funky it's kind of cool his other
partner owned like a like a I think it
was called reboot it was like a sauna
that you could go to an LA but Co
happens so both of those businesses get
screwed and so they're like man we got
to figure something out and they noticed
that at their places people were asking
for coal plunges and they also saw that
online I think at the time it was like
15 grand to get a coal plunge as opposed
to what a lot of people do what I used
to do in college is you get like a big
trash can and you just got to go to like
7-Eleven and buy ice and fill your your
thing up your your bucket with with
water hose uh or hose uh water from the
hose and it takes forever whatever and
they're like all right let's create our
own so 2020 they did 270,000 in Revenue
2021 they did 8 million 2022 I think we
got it in 21 or 22 whenever Andrew came
on 2022 they did 33 million in Revenue
this year 2023 they're doing around 10
million a month and they're going to
surpass 100 million in Vue off freaking
cold plunges it's wild insane and the
way they the way he told me they got
started was they basically DMD Aubrey
Marcus who's this health guy on
Instagram who owns on it and they were
like hey man we're gonna we'll come to
your house and just set up a cold plunge
for free and so they get a U-Haul and
they fill it up with this like little
homemade thing that they did they Ed
like a bunch of parts from Home Depot
I'd imagine because I have an early
version it looks like something you
could kind of hack together and they
brought it to his place and they set it
up for him and they were like is there
anyone else you think we should talk to
and he's like yeah huberman talk to this
guy and so they get a U-Haul and they
fill it up with five more and they start
delivering it to these guys and I guess
that's how I got it plunge tour they
would they fill up four or five of these
go on a plunge tour and they would
Instagram while they were doing it and
so people on IG would see it like like
me I would see it on IG and it' be like
damn this must be like some super
successful company cuz they're they're
they're only delivering to people that I
know like you know influencers basically
even though there were no other
customers it was only those customers
yeah and there's it was only like a few
of them it was like they they they threw
this thing together and I guess that's
when I kind that's when Andrew like I
guess they were like Andrew you know we
have this money for you to give away do
you want to give away to whoever they
gave one to me they gave one to sill
they so far they've given away hundreds
of these things and they're killing it
and never in a million years would have
thought a cold plune business would do
north of 100 million in Revenue by the
way they've given away over a thousand
plunges that's insane right that's like
the that means influencer marketing was
like so important uh to to them at the
beginning our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better a couple
other fun facts got I say a couple of
these that you have on your notes yeah
do it they bought plunge. comom off of a
New Orleans jazz band for
250k which is just hilarious that's a
that's wild they basically are riding
this wave so if you look on Google
Trends we'll put this up on the screen
on on YouTube you could see basically
cold plunge versus ice bath and just
both of them rising over time as like
you know the kind of the huberman era
kicks in here so they they're right in
the back of that but the insane thing is
this ads spend you got to talk about
this you talk about it because this is
in your this is your wheelhouse but
basically what they did was they um Ryan
I've met Ryan he's almost like he he I
don't know the best way to describe it
but he's one of these guys that was
doing iasa before iasa was cool like
when I went and hung out with him like
he had his toenails painted because like
there's something around that I don't
exactly know what it is but there's like
something around that like he's like
eccentric and I don't think he probably
knew anything about Google ads or
Facebook ads and so he said he hired a
guy on upwork to help run Google ads for
them and that's how they started so what
and and he even sent me a screenshot
basically it shows their revenue it
shows their ad spend it shows it broke
it down on Google Facebook and even Bing
a little bit but like just looking at
their total paid media I want to zoom in
on this this is these are kind of
Bonkers numbers so this is is this a
month wait what what is this I think
this is last monthly I think this is
monthly which is crazy so last month I
don't know if it's last month but one
month 860,000 in ad spend so 860k in a
month and then their row as on that
return on ad spend was
7.1 to get just to put this in this is
the that's bananas nobody has seven or
eight X row as they said they've had
that basically from the beginning they
they used to get uh 10 over 10x now it's
sort of like between seven and 10x um to
get a 7x row as that means you're it's
you have a machine they put a box in
this guy's house and it's a magic box
and the box says if you put $1 into this
box you get $7 out that's what that
means and so they have this box that
they're able to put $800,000 in each
month and get out you know6 million I
dollar back and they're just doing that
month after month after month and so you
see it on Google their roaz is you know
5.8 on Facebook it's 10.7 I don't know
why they're saying this by the way I
would never reveal this information if I
if I found a magic box that does this uh
you know I would never share this with
anybody but they said to do it so you
know here here you go I think maybe they
think they're they're pretty far ahead
in terms of competition but I don't know
that if they can get these numbers
anyone can get these numbers on Facebook
there's not they have no Special Sauce
there that that's going to be you know
uncopyable I guess why why did they
agree to share this I just said I'm
going to talk about you in the Pod like
let me interview you and I said whatever
we talk about this is like on the record
uh so I guess if they change their mind
they'll let me know well I mean it's
cool that they get a big feature that's
cool but also this is crazy and just
props to them these numbers are insane
so basically they own the whole thing so
they bootstrap they haven't taken any
funding and this is by the way 2020 so
they're coming up at four years so on
Facebook and this snapshot here uh if
this is accurate the the SN this the CAC
on Facebook so the cost to acquire a
customer on Facebook for them is
$387 they're selling this thing for
$5,000 so you can see you're paying just
under 400 bucks to get somebody to pay
you 5,000 bucks uh amazing trade on on
the ad spend and you could see why this
thing is scaling so crazy you know over
wild 8 million 33 million and now over
100 million and they bootstrapped it
this is profitable they didn't raise any
outside money and now they're expanding
into like saunas and other too so
that's pretty insane what do you think
this company could sell for let's say
they they get to I have no idea what the
profit is let's say they get to 100 so
2020 they started at 200 a quarter
million dollars me 2020 in year four
their fourth year business they're going
to do 100 million what could this sell
for is this could this be a two or300
million company definitely definitely um
you know I would if you're getting like
just to put this in perspective if
you're getting adx Raz on your money and
let's say that continues let's say they
can if they said they're doing you know
whatever eight to 10 million a month so
they're over $100 million say 120
million in
Revenue the minimum that they should be
selling for is onx revenue so 120
million in this case let's say that
because of their growth rate because of
the insane profitability on their on
their ads this company has to be you
know Mak a bank right like normally
people most people in e-commerce are
Break Even or slightly losing money on
first
order the you know that gets you that's
like you have a row as of like between
one and two these guys are doing you
know six or seven times better than that
so so that's kind of insane this company
should be worth you know 250 $300
million right now you know I I don't
know how big that clear light Sonic
company is but I'm pretty sure it's
pretty big man if I'm these guys I might
take that sale that to make that amount
of money in three or four years and I
don't know what their financial
situation was before but let's just
assume that they were just getting by
owning a brick andmar business that's
why
that that is a crazy story I would take
advantage of that or I would sell like
$30 million of secondary I would sell
like $30 million at even like a $100
million valuation and dilute 30% only
but now you guys you know you put 15
million bucks in the bank and you can
keep going if you really want to keep
going that's what I would do uh in this
case because you could bank that huge
life-changing sum uh because these
e-commerce companies let's say that you
know ad flips competition flips whatever
they don't like retain that much value
because the s is already done in the
past you basically get no credit for
past you know past sales here because
it's not recurring Revenue it's not like
a network effect style business so you
know you're really only as good as your
next year when it comes to e-commerce I
think at least so yeah I would I would
definitely take some money off the table
it's crazy though and and by the way I
don't know like what the science is
behind Cold plunging I still I've had
how long have I owned it for two or
three years I still use it three days a
week like I'm into it it's clinically
proven to make you post on social media
at least three times more so that's one
proven effect there was this one Tik Tok
where these guys were joking they were
like you know it's crazy to think about
it but for the first 20 minutes after
the Titanic sank the passengers were
actually healthier uh until they died
uh they actually were increasing their
lifespan by 20% during that first cold
plch until they suddenly
died they're like they're like too bad
whim Hoff wasn't there to teach him how
to breathe right uh they reduce their
risk of heart attack they're like
they're like imagine if whim Hoff was
there like this feels
nice but there was about 15 minutes with
he should do he should Rebrand to the
Titanic method he should be like oh you
don't do Titanic breathing this was this
would save you would live even if you on
the Titanic if you learned this
there was about 15 minutes where they
were in Peak Physical
shape um anyway that's the update on
pledge I finally got an on them I'm
shocked at how they're doing um I guess
I'm not that shocked it's $5,000 product
I guess I guess I'm shocked at how many
people would buy into this never in a
million years would I've thought this
many people would buy into this and want
to get cold however many times a week um
so that's my update on plunge I got one
thing I want to jump right into it's
something that's been on my mind it's
been grinding my gears it's been a
little uh a little itch I need to
scratch and that is supplement testing
so you're a big supplements guy it
sounds like you're setting up an ad by
the way we have to say this is not an ad
no no this is not an ad this is just me
being uh corny so uh I've been thinking
about this idea because I've been buying
a ton of supplements and um I don't
know about you but like people are like
oh you know you take that I'm like yeah
they're like um how how do like is it
working I'm like how the how would
I know it's a supplement you never know
if a supplements working right like I
feel that way I don't know if I'm just
not in tune with my body when you take
stuff do you have like a clear like this
is helping me versus this is not when it
comes to actual like supplements there's
basically only one or two supplements
that I've ever taken where I'm like this
is working so I take either melatonin or
magnesium at night um and that's the
only those are the only two where I'm
like all right I'm it helps me go to
sleep faster besides that protein so but
protein is it protein is a supplement
but it's you know it's it's a nutrient
so like when I eat more protein whether
it comes through a powder or not I
notice my muscles get bigger besides
that I don't think I've noticed a
difference in mostly anything even
protein for me it's not even like I feel
my muscles getting bigger I just feel
more full so I'm like okay that did
something like that is like kind of like
a meal replacement uh got it but like
even creatine I started taking creatine
and um I thought that creatine would
be I thought creatine was going to be
the hard I was like oh okay here we
go I've crossed the line I'm doing the
hard now now it's just going to be
like a little unfair these gains that
I'm about to be having can't feel
anything you with no I don't feel
anything when I was taking testosterone
I felt that but that's I don't know if
that would be under the the the heading
of supplements but like basically if
it's illegal or banded Sports I've
noticed a difference besides that if I
could buy it if I could buy it at Target
I don't know if I've noticed a
difference right if you're not having to
text a guy guy to get it you're not
going to feel it so I feel like with
supplements There's an opportunity the
opportunity with supplements is to be
the most trusted Source when it comes to
supplements so for you where do you go
when you want to find out if which brand
you should be taking or which brand you
should not be taking or what's the most
effective what's the cleanest what's the
healthiest for you where do you go to
get that information right now so I use
examine.com to figure out which uh
supplements are like which the science
has shown that it works but examine.com
the brand right that's yeah exam.com in
order to stay neutral they don't promote
any Brands right and so I go to Amazon I
talk to friends it it's pretty
challenging it's also challenging
because do you remember the mattress
review websites like the top one it
ended up being owned by Casper exactly
and so it was incredibly challenging to
find like which like for example some
protein Brands will say we have 25 gram
of protein per scoop and then you go
research it and it's like no this one
actually only has 18 or this has some
certif certification which means they
had to jump through this hoop or that
hoop it's actually quite challenging to
figure out who's clean and who to trust
yeah I think it was Casper that owned
was it Casper or purple that that owned
a bunch of the the top mattress blogs
that had like they were like for 15
years they were like a normal blog and
they went bottom out and then they like
started promoting their own and
it's a same thing with with supplements
you know like the what's rule number one
if you create a protein brand you go you
buy your brand name your domain and then
you buy the truth abpr docomo need that
too in order to promote your own
it's really hard it's really hard the
reality is that supplements health and
wellness are on the way up uh people are
are it's becoming more and more normal
to take a wider and wider variety of
these things there's more and more
brands in the market because now you
have dtoc Brands so anyone can create a
brand you don't need to fight for shelf
space because you could just be on the
internet the infinite shelf and I think
the need has become bigger than ever for
somebody to become The Trusted person
and I say person specifically here The
Trusted person around supplement testing
and um have you seen this guy flave City
no how do you spell it f La V uh then
City so flave city is this guy that my
mom will send me my mom will always send
me the thing so this guy's stick is
genius like in terms of content creation
this is such a good Niche and um it is
so perfect so what he does is he's like
I'm a trusted guy I'm not like some
super expert or whatever but I just I'm
a guy who knows things what he does is
he goes to a grocery store if you go
look at his Instagram he'll go to a
grocery store be like Costco he'd be
like the thumbnail is him holding up
let's say parmesan cheese and he'll be
like don't buy this see and he'll turn
it around he'd be like see it has
parmesan cheese milk that's fine but
then it has artificial flavors we don't
like artificial flavors because they're
gonna be bad for blah blah blah instead
buy this one and he'll have another one
at Costco that's better he's like see
this one doesn't have artificial flavors
doesn't have this it does have this but
it's the best one you can find at Costco
so he's doing it right now on Instagram
he's doing it for veggie straws which is
like those potato chips that are like
whatever they're supposedly made out of
vegetables he goes this is bad for this
reason here are some Le uh here here are
some better ones for you lesser evil
power curls ciete Puffs Jackson's sweet
potato chips and you and he looks at the
back of veggie straws and he tells you
what's wrong with it right and I'm
giving this to my kids right veggie
straws oh that's better than chips
veggies right and it's like so he's he
just debunks a lot of things and he's
got his whole thing he's very high
energy he does mainstream products that
are in shopping Cent uh in shopping
stores and he'll be like um this one
Bobby approved and he's like got his own
little stick where he's like this is
Bobby approved and he's like he's
basically Doug deorro but for you know
um packaged Goods instead of cars he has
2.5 million followers that post of the
veggie straw ones that I just said has
25,000 likes exactly cuz it's super
fortable because as soon as he says
something and you know somebody who eats
that you share it with them and then he
becomes a trusted Source he's not
selling you anything he's just telling
you better and worse he's telling you
what to avoid or he's like okay it's
it's the holiday he's got one holiday
booze Hall it's like these are the
things to you know to buy and de buy
when it comes to booze or farm salmon
does farm salmon good or bad and he just
uses the like thinker Emoji so you're
like oh is there something I need
to know about armed salmon is that not
is that not healthy I thought that was
um he's got another one ditch the
Goldfish right so he's taking these
popular products he's doing this so I
think this is genius I think more people
should literally just copy him um
because there's room for more here and
you could differentiate by being you
know a mom who's going to be trusted by
moms and do more mom products than than
what he's doing or you could be a meat
head who's doing more protein gym Jim
bro type of content that's kind of what
more place more dates is doing but I
think this format is beautiful so let me
just tell you about this opportunity
okay so here here's how I'm thinking
about this do you know Consumer Reports
they test like every product ellipticals
and you know uh coffee machines and
whatever else do you know about the
company itself Consumer Reports I do we
brought them up I'm not gonna I'm not
going to steal your steas here but it's
wild it's wild well they're nonprofit do
you know that you could give give me an
accurate guess you don't have to give me
the homie guess where you guess low just
to make me feel good give me what you
think the real guess is their revenue
per year do you know 100 almost 300
million a year 289 that's insane it's
crazy right and it's all subscription
Revenue what's that it's all
subscription Revenue too I think uh yeah
I don't know the exact mix but it's it's
a nonprofit so you can actually go find
a bunch of their stuff um so and they
have like 250 million of assets on their
books which like nonprofits are are
famous for like having you know High
Revenue High expenses and then just like
a a lot of assets on the books and so
you have to you have to spend A1 UH 60
bucks a year in order to get access to
their articles and it's old it's old as
hell like you go there and literally
like the website looks old you know like
when you see videos of people from like
the '90s or the 80s and it's just like
the haircuts are old the fashion is old
it's all old and like these people have
80s haircuts and I just realized when I
saw this it's time for a new Consumer
Reports JD Power does this for cars
right JD Power what is it JD Power and
Associates I don't know who these people
are I don't know what they do 240
million a year in Revenue so I think
there's an opportunity to create the new
age Consumer Reports JD Power around
supplements specifically and I would do
it in the Tik Tok format so what flave
city is doing I would do it that way and
I would test every single product and I
would test it in a scientific way that
people can't so they claim that it has
this many you know grams of protein per
scoop let's find out Truth or Dare right
I dare you to have the amount of protein
you say and you do a little 15-second 30
second video that's kind of uh you know
talking about each one of these products
the beauty of short form video is for
the Mr B said this to me and I and I
kind of was like huh I never really
thought about this before he goes for
the first time ever short form video is
the only content format that can be
posted on every social network at the
same time I was like what he's like yeah
basically let's take uh you know
Instagram is a single photo that's
filtered cool you could post that on
Instagram you could kind of post it on
Facebook you might be able to post that
on Twitter but it wasn't the native way
of doing things and you know like but
you can't post that on Snapchat the same
way like you can't do that but with
short form video you can literally get
on Tik Tok YouTube uh Instagram Facebook
Snapchat every single social network is
compatible with short short fromont
video which means short font video is
now the dominant the dominant content
format to be creating it and um I so I
think if you do this you could go across
all of them you can't monetize that the
so typically the way there's basically
two ways that you maybe there's three
there's two main ways you monetize this
so there's affiliate which is
wirecutter.com I've got a I know a guy
named Dennis who started bestreviews.com
he sold it for $110 million to the worst
named company on Earth it was called
trunk which was uh it's basically the
company I think that owns LA Times uh
and he sold it for 110 million bucks
after trun should definitely be like a
women's jeans brand that's like trun all
about your butt or something yeah trunk
is a horrible name got junk in the trunk
you know what I'm saying
it's a really bad name it's one of those
names that sounds like a noise uh and so
they they sold the trunk I I think after
four years and they monetized it the
same way as wire cutter so it was
through affiliate but wire cutter is one
of the few I think NerdWallet does a
good job where they do trust where some
for some reason I still trust them even
though I know they're getting paid per
click right uh and then the other one
which is harder to pull off but a way
better business is um subscription and
that's what Consumer Report does you
know why wire cutter I think can has
that trust even though they're clearly
pushing you know they're clearly making
money off the recommendations I think
it's two things one it's like good
design and copyrighting so it feels like
a person is talking to you and it feels
like it's like clean same with the
Points Guy they're not saying who's the
best what they're say what they do is
they say best on a budget this is the
one we recommend if if price is no no
problem this is the best one period on
the market and then kind of the most
common popular option is this one so
instead of it being here's our favorite
and yeah it's the one we're getting the
best kick back on they kind of give you
options of like depending on your
situation we think this is the best in
that situation and I feel like for some
reason that changes and then it's like
yeah we we make money you know we get an
affiliate on each one of these but like
they're all equal we're not saying one
is better than the other we're saying
one is better in this situation so I
think that and one of the reasons why I
think they do that is I know the
founders of NerdWallet and if I remember
correctly so nerdwallet.com SLB best-
credit-card so that's one page if I
remember correctly that one so basically
their whole business model was to make
that page rank number one in Google if
you search best credit card and for a
long time that one page was making like
40 million of their like $45 million a
year in sales and then they were like
all right now we need to do best credit
card for students best credit card for
fixed income people best credit card for
your firsttime credit card and they had
to diversify because best nerdwallet.com
bestest credit card was getting all of
their sales it was that that and their
whole company strategy was write
articles that get linked back from like
uh you know USA news.com or business
inside or whatever get high quality
links and then in those articles link
back tobest credit card it it was a
pretty wild strategy and it worked or
it's working yeah you basically want to
write articles that get linked so your
overall domain Authority goes up but
then you got one or two Money Maker
pages and those are those are the pages
that you need to be the number one
search result for the way you do it is
by creating all this Goodwill around the
other Pages this sort of SEO Goodwill so
I think you would think that short form
video is hard to monetize but that's not
what you're monetizing you're not
monetizing the short for video You're
monetizing the trust so today who is
both the most trusted voice in science
and supplements and the man most likely
to be in Sam's
fantasies yeah my husband Andrew hberman
exactly and as a what do they call them
my my hubman husbands or something like
that um what did they say uh so I I
posted a shirtless picture of him and
he's like and I and I was like uh people
were like what do they say they're I'm
Huber I'm Huber's man uh yeah he he
posted his first shirtless video the
other day and uh men around the world
were gasping clear the calendar
honey yeah all right so huberman makes
money through his ads and his podcast
but remember when Rob deerdick was on
the Pod and he was talking about
momentus protein and he's like yeah
momentus was kind of dead in the water
we thought we had made the best cleanest
protein but really wasn't going anywhere
and then we did a deal with Andrew
huberman and we were like how much did
you pay him and he goes I don't know
whatever it was it wasn't enough it
wasn't enough and he was just like
laughing at like how crazy that that was
so you know I think the business model
here is you build trust for a couple
years and then you come out with your
own branded supplement right you want to
be in the supplements game you don't
want to be that ruins your whole premise
though of finding the most trusted no no
no no you you are the most trusted you
build the trust by say and then finally
you say look I've had it with these
companies I've had it with these I am
just going to make the one that I wish
existed the one that is truly clean that
is going to hold the up utmost standard
right Derek from more plates more dates
that's exactly what he did uh somebody
like Jessica Alo with Honest Company
kind of did the same thing she built up
a bunch of Fame and Trust in one area
but then she comes out with the Honest
Company and she's like this is going to
be the honest brand the product I want
to give to my kids which by the way I
buy momentous protein in part because I
trust Rob and Rob was involved and I buy
bpn which is uh Nick bear you know the
Jack guy who runs fast I was like these
guys both seem trustworthy I'll buy
their stuff so I spend all my money with
them right because what else do you have
to go on you have nothing else to go on
this packaging or that packaging right
like what else do you have to go on
besides the words of somebody you trust
and so I think that's the way you do
this ultimately is you uh you ultimately
build your own supplement franchise
around this more like The Honest Company
but I think first for a couple years you
are just becoming the most viral trusted
Source when it comes to the truth about
X and you got to pick things that are
going to be very sharable um as well as
you know you know establish your
Authority in that Niche to be able to
I'm I'm the most knowledgeable trusted
Source when it comes to what should I be
taking
by the way we've talked about the Eat
This Not That category and we we loved
it I think we talked about it a year and
a half or two years ago we love to eat
This Not That category it's the best I
love that when did we say that because I
remember talking about Flav City because
that's his thing right Eat This Not That
he was doing we I thought I mentioned it
maybe a year ago uh but I really hadn't
like fully wrapped my head around it so
eat This Not That was a line of books um
I remember buying it Barnes & Noble like
I don't even know how to say how do you
say I used to call them Barnes & Nobles
uh I remember buying it at Barnes &
Nobles uh years ago when I was like in
fourth grade it was Eat This Not That
and it would just show a picture of
Doritos and then it would show an
alternative and it would explain why it
was a massive hit for a book series and
I remember buying like all of them um
and I think we said we're like fine for
a book but this has to be beyond that
and we talked about it I think with
Steph two years ago yes yes so I think
this is a a clear like content Niche
that can turn into a pretty Monster
business um and there's a bunch of
different and there's a bunch of
different angles depending on who you
are Derek for more plates more dates
obviously hits the Jim bro Market but
then flave city hits the like Mom shop
Costco Shopper market and you should
just keep there's there's a lot more
niches than that the New York Times did
this article the other day or a few
weeks ago and it was my Guru is better
than your Guru and they talked about how
people like you and I you know you you
and I are team hberman but then there's
this other group who's team Peter AA and
then there's this other one who's team
Peter like my father-in-law loves this
guy named Mark uh mark kind ofan or
something like that uh and it's like
well my Guru said this and it's just
crazy how we find these guys that we
stick to and whatever they say we don't
know like I can't tell you entirely what
why herberman suggests X Y and Z but I
know he suggested that and I will go to
bat and fight other people who their
gurus said X Y and Z and I don't even
know why I just know that I trust Andrew
that's my guy and I thought it was
really interesting how it is turning
into to be something like that have you
ever heard this explanation of why
gossip exists
evolutionarily no it's sort of nerdy but
it's it's kind of fascinating so
everything has uh a value right like
even like what we consider negative
emotions like fear why does Fear have
value well you know if you're hunter
gatherer and there's a lion you know
fear or paranoia can be a very useful
survival tool and and you needed to be
super fearful and paranoid at a certain
period of time maybe less so today but
we can see why that's evolutionarily
baked in but that that applies to
everything and so gossip is a good
example gossip if you just talk to most
people gossip negative thing right
shouldn't do it bad you know poor form
it's a it's sort of a lowly thing to do
and actually gossip is extremely useful
so you think about uh humans live in
tribes and and we're in this Society
well it's impossible for me to know one
by one with each person about their
character and their reputation myself
through only firsthand experiences and
so how does a tribe function well gossip
is actually a necessary thing I should
know that if this person's untrustworthy
because rumors should spread so that the
tribe as a whole becomes almost immune
to this charlatan uh through gossip and
I don't have to myself go and have a
firsthand bad experience so in that way
gossip has saved me from getting my you
know my hand burned off on the stove
many times and so I kind of feel like
the the same thing exists where it's
sort of silly in a way to uh you just
trust these online influencers these
gurus don't you know they're just trying
to sell you something well yeah and
there's there's some amount of that but
at the same time what am I going to do
go test all my supplements myself like
the inefficiency that would be brought
in if I didn't trust these people what
am I going to go read all the white
papers myself about clinical studies no
I'm not going to do that I'm gonna we're
all gonna Outsource that task to
somebody and we're going to trust them
until they burn our trust and then we're
going to move on to the next one but
like EV almost like as a tribe it is the
if efficient way to do things even
though it's kind of seen as this low IQ
move it's actually not a low IQ move it
is the like sort of like Game Theory
optimal move to trust people or to trust
gossip in certain situations where
you're not going to want to do the
firsthand work yourself look if George
Forman tells me what Grill is best for
my brw worst I listen to George he looks
like he eats a lot of brator no I get it
where uh did you just go and read a book
on gossiping where did you get this I
heard this a long time ago and uh you
know my brain was just connecting the
dots just now I I want to tell you about
another Health company that's related to
all this but before you do we have a
quick segment it's called Thrill of the
shill and so it's a time where we're
Each G to take a turn your turn is is
this time to promote whatever we want
but it's the thrill to shill because
you're G to shill something but you're
going to Thrill me a little bit so about
eight months ago you invested in a
company called Shephard yeah you sent me
a graph I get up updates every once in a
while I try not to get too much
information because I don't ever want to
reveal something I'm not supposed to
reveal but you sent me a graph things
are going more than good I think I think
it's you could say how many times it's
multiplied but now is your 60c thrill
the shill moment amazing oh the pressure
is on to Thrill with this shill listen
the way I'm going to make this thrilling
is I'm going to share a little info all
right share a little info not about the
business and the internal numbers
necessarily but about what's working so
I can what I can say high level we uh
the business was already doing great
before we joined compan called Shephard
and what they do is they basically make
it easy to hire so I was using them to
hire for my e-commerce company because I
wanted to hire more people but I didn't
have the budget so I was like all right
Shephard has talent in the Philippines
in latam so like we needed a Shopify
developer all right I can either pay an
a expensive agency or hire some guy but
I found a guy for 2500 a month who's
awesome and I did the same thing with
customer support and I did the same
thing with all a whole bunch of these
roles and so I was using them and I was
like this is a great business and I'm
going to buy into it so I bought into it
and since then the business have
basically tripled so we've tripled the
business in eight months and the
business was already doing well to begin
with so that was kind of like way
exceeded expectations now what actually
worked well when I joined I thought all
right boys I'm coming in hot I got ideas
I don't know if you've heard I got a
business podcast I think I know a thing
or two about business why don't you
listen to my ideas and I had all these
like exotic ways that I thought we could
you know make things better in the
reality was the the big lesson the big
takeaway here
was a lesson that I had heard early on
in the podcast there was a guy who came
on this podcast I don't remember his
name but he made this he has this bag
company Peak design forgot his his first
name sorry but Peak design and I was
like dude you sell like 80 million doar
worth of this like camera bag what the
hell man like what's your what was your
growth hack what's your secret and he's
like oh dude I used to listen to all
these business gurus and they talk about
this like Advanced planning and like you
know like long long-term thinking and
super strategic stuff he goes to me
business is the six inches right in
front of your face and I was like what
and I was like this is also the speech
From Any Given Sunday and he's like yes
business is the six inches in front of
your face and you just got to keep
knocking out the six inches and so when
we were talking about shephard I was
like all right well you know cool ideas
Sean but like what's the six inches
right in front of our face and uh we
basically did one thing one thing that
really really worked uh and the one
thing that really worked that was not
expected for me was they just did a very
simple analysis they go how do we get
more of our best compers customers and
less of our worst customers which is I
think an exercise anybody should do like
did you ever do this with either
advertisers at the hustle or like or
Hampton like did you ever def like
bucket out like who are the best
customers who are the worst customers
because the worst customers take up 80%
of your time basically what happens is
you get in this habit of where you're
just like I'll take any amount I'll take
any customer and take any money whatever
I'll just do whatever and then you get
all these people and then you're
like oh my God this sucks like this guy
takes so much time and I don't even make
that much money from them I have to
learn who do I fire and who who's who
who do I go after instead exactly and
what most people do is they do it at the
beginning which I think is the wrong
move because at the beginning you don't
really know and you do need to be just a
little bit desperate and kind of Brute
Force things but there's a point where
you got to check in like you know if it
nine months in you haven't checked in do
this checkin which is basically draw a
little piece of paper and write our top
you know 10 to 20% of customers and our
bottom 10 to 20% of customers bottom is
like drag out your time lowest profit um
you know like most headache most support
required and then the top is the
opposite and so we did this little
exercise and the thing we realized was
we thought the business was people
hiring virtual assistants because that
was the most common thing people would
come in for right you come in you need a
VA just to do some tasks or maybe it's a
personal assistant for you or help with
travel booking meeting scheduling that
stuff and it does do that that's fine
but then we were like yo who's this
group of customers that they hire twice
as much as everybody else and
the like LTV the lifetime value of these
customers is also like you know 40 50%
higher so who was it and it was people
who needed
bookkeepers I was like what and they're
like yeah bookkeepers and they're like
you know the reason we didn't see it is
because it's all concentrated in certain
spikes so basically bookkeepers
everybody hires them after tax season
it's like you go through the pain of tax
season and then you're like all right
never again am I going to feel that um
and so you're like companies will
basically hire a bookkeeper like dude it
was such a mess a Time suck this year we
just need a b a bookkeeper and we're
like a small business we don't need like
a fancy bookkeeper let's hire an
overseas book bookkeeper and so they
they do that or accounting firms or
anybody who is a tax tax company they
need more bookkeepers or they're a
bookkeeping firm they need more
bookkeepers and so they would hire they
would hire lots of the same talent that
Talent is priced a little bit more so
there's more profit on that hire and so
anyways we just just by identifying one
little thing but there was like three
things like that that we did those were
the like tweaks that weren't very sexy
that made a big difference that's so
kind of that's my little my my thrill of
the shill today is to to remind you go
do that little 8020 exercise on best and
worst customers once you're like I don't
know about right around a year into the
business because it will refocus you in
a good way you got to give the URL oh
yeah so go to support shepard.com for
whatever you need to hire for whether
it's bookkeepers virtual assistants
developers designers they got you know
basically they go find the top 1% of
talent in these countries they got boots
on the ground there're like literally
interviewing people and then you can go
find the Elite Talent there for
basically 80% less than if you hire
people in the states all right that's
the thrill of the show that's pretty
good pretty good first thrill shill yeah
I I was thrilled um all right so let's
do another one so I got
uh I got one thing for you so did you
see Trung tweeted this out and I found
this kind of interesting so he tweeted
out about this Chinese quibby did you
ever see this tweet no but is it
working so uh yeah I think it is which
is the funny part so is it Chinese as in
in China or for Chinese American but
Chinese content it's Chinese like Tik
Tok is Chinese it's made by a Chinese
company but it's at the top of the US
charts it's a company called real short
real short it's called real short um so
basically here's what he says it's
bite-sized English scripted video
content so it's like quibby but instead
of paying for Hollywood hitters it's
cheesy degrad soap operas homark films
the shows are all about Affairs scandals
marital Intrigue and absurd plots for
example son-in-law's Revenge I'm getting
married without you or never divorce a
secret billionaire ays let me just pause
here I'm in on real short okay that was
all I needed to hear I this is this
smells like a winner to me all right so
so I I like this General concept short
video that's scripted versus just like
people's you know Tik toks um but it's
like junk food it's junk food content um
it's it's like you know Mory poic
Hallmark film like you know it's just
stuff that like it's not highbrow it
Just appeals to people people are gen
you know people have to turn their head
to to look at this stuff it's like
Hallmark right so he goes a show is
typically 50 episodes each episode's
only 90 to 120 seconds each um they
started off by adapting a bunch of
Chinese romance like kind of soap operas
for Western audiences um it's free to
watch but you watch ads uh to unlock
more episodes or you could pay coins to
unlock them faster um Tech crunch
estimates that this app has been
downloaded 11 million times already
across IOS and Android and generated
over $22 million in Revenue since August
2022 so $22 million in year one not bad
uh it's owned by this Chinese Company Co
group and they're expanding Their
audience because the shows were so kind
of like addictive and like you know bad
that they banned in China so where do
you go America the Las Vegas of the
world where anything goes and so they
brought it here um pretty crazy and so
so don't you what do you think of this
concept I'm it's this is insane to me so
the actors and actresses they're white
people so is it white is it like are
they appealing to as this is po
Americans it's like everything else made
in China made four Americans so who's
who who's buying I mean so this is just
boggling mind so you know Hallmark you
know Hallmark like you know the cards
and channel familiar so that that
company still does about 5 billion in
Revenue I think it's a familyowned
business so it's still like a huge thing
so the hmar is it the shops plus the TV
or are they separate businesses it's uh
so the whole company does five billion
in sales um but I think a a significant
amount of the revenue is not from cards
I think it's from the the channel so it
says worldwide Hallmark has 27,000
employees
holy crap um so and Hallmark channel is
like a big line of their business which
I think they sold part of it to uh
Liberty Media and so it it's like a huge
Company still and I think it's it's
family-owned based out of
Missouri yeah yeah that's great uh okay
so Hallmark's great so you're
in it just tell me you're in so a few
years ago I I've told this before my
friend Ramon and I ran a test where we
created this book called um captivating
CLA I think that's what it was was it
called captivating CLA and basically
Ramone ran a soap opera website and he
had this guy on his staff that loved to
write short stories and they were erotic
short stories and what we did was we
created a WordPress blog a WordPress
blog and I think we called it short but
romantic. and basically over the weekend
we he had wrote a story on a Friday on
on Friday night the WordPress blog was
made and at the very bottom of the
WordPress blog it was basically just one
page of a blog post and it said uh we
hope you enjoyed this first iteration of
of captivating CLA from short but for
short but romantic if you want to see
part two here's a PayPal link it's $10 a
month sign up and we will mail you the
part two of the story next week when it
comes out and we used Fiverr and we got
a narrator to do it this whole project
took $400 we drove tra traffic for it
the next day on Saturday we had like
$300 in sales um and we were like holy
crap and if you look up the blog you
might have to use web archive to do it
uh but because I think we took it down
or the domain expired I remember reading
it if you look at the blog and you go to
the comment section you'll see these
people were obsessed with this they were
like oh my God Claire did this I can't
wait to read part two and it was
mindboggling and then we were on Sunday
we were like we don't really want to be
in this business business like this
doesn't really fit our interest uh I
think he should still should have done
it well he he was going to he he Ramon
was going to do this business we we both
invested in him he was about to do this
business and then one of his other
businesses kind of took off so that that
be yeah dog ramps took off but he was
like really dead set on this and I was
like I don't know it seems like it could
be pretty great and this real short is
proof that that that that that idea I
think was on to something it's it's I
was amazed at young women what they
wanted to buy me and you were
undoubtedly you know uh we're trying
hard with this channel we go every every
week we work on this channel we have a
we have YouTube and it's growing we're
doing we're doing great small and mighty
we've been climbing up the charts and in
about a year we got to about 350,000
subscribers and when we really knock it
out of the park with a great episode we
might get few hundred thousand views
well just go look at real short on
YouTube so somebody started uploading
the real short episodes but like the
like episodes 1 through 20 together so
real short romance um 330,000
subscribers they posted a video uh like
two months ago and it has uh you know
it's it's the double life of my
billionaire husband 3.7 million views go
look at the comments it's exactly what
you're talking about Christine Joy says
I hope there will be more video from
these two the chemistry they have hard
Emoji prer Emoji dude and they're not
even optimized they have a real short uh
watermark on them and it's vertical
video yeah exactly and then another
person you know Jolan Bongo 96996 says
oh I watched this on Facebook reals I
got hooked by it I love the story and
the cast good job guys I can't wait for
the next episodes and there are
thousands of comments uh in this comment
thread that are all about I can't wait
for the next episodes I love the
storyline this is better than Hollywood
oh my God I'm hooked this is working um
and this is you know what is my take
here so my take is number one
interesting business that I never heard
of good job trunk I I never heard about
this so I'm glad he put this on my radar
second thing the difference between a
good idea and a bad IDE idea is just a
few small decisions quibby gets made fun
of as a classic Silicon Valley idiotic
startup it's like oh man remember quibby
it's like a it's like the butt of a joke
in Silicon Valley uh yeah this will be
as successful as quibby quby I think was
the right idea small micro content like
you know TV shows shrank down I think
can be really successful the problem was
they raised two billion dollar and spent
it all on like really high production
quality stuff that wasn't that juicy and
never got people hooked
um whereas real short is basically like
starting with getting people hooked and
then figuring out you know the rest as
it goes the third thing is the third
takeaway is why do I have so much faith
in the Chinese like when I even started
to read his tweet I was like oh a
Chinese Company's trying to do quibby
but better and I was like probably gonna
work I would bet more on this random
Chinese company that I've never heard of
than Jeffrey kenberg the guy who created
quibby that was like the creator of
DreamWorks and why is that I don't know
maybe it's because through my Ecom brand
I like do business with you know Chinese
companies and the way they run their
businesses I mean like that's my real
MBA is when I talk to like the factory
owner in China about how he's running
his business and I watch how he moves
and he came out here to meet us and
we're talking to him and you know just
that the way they conduct themselves is
awesome the way they work is awesome the
like level of complexity they can like
handle is awesome and it used to just be
with manufacturing only and then Tik Tok
came and was a total narrative violation
it was like oh you think they could just
you know make cheap plastic toys no no
no watch this we'll make the hit social
app that's all about cool and culture
we'll appeal to the US team better than
an American startup could amazing to me
it's a lack of ego is what it is so uh
quibby was this cool La company I think
they even reached out to you and I
they're like you guys want to make
content for this show
bued yeah I was like I I I I don't know
but but not that we're quote cool guys
but we we are based in San Francisco and
we lived a on paper what seemed like an
interesting life like people building
startups whereas let's say it if you
were gonna spend money on us to start
your platform your platform is gonna
fail all right obviously we we
should not be part of your platform but
they went after like cool people like
you know I imagine they had like high
like big- time celebrities and like
that whereas I think a lot of people in
Silicon Valley and La I think they do
the same thing you know if you look at a
lot of the DDC Brands it's like they
spend most of their money on
branding some agency that was overpriced
with lowercase letters based out of
Brooklyn and in reality like this whole
Middle America I think particularly
since a lot of entrepreneurs in the tech
Bas are young men they forget that
there's this whole contingency of 150
million people who are at home and they
just want to goof around and watch
something like this and their ego
prevents them from creating something
that's quote low quality which exactly
this fits that bill you would see this
and you're like this is stupid no one
will watch this whereas someone else who
just like yeah dude I just want to win I
just want to do whatever it says I'm
going to follow the numbers and I think
a lot of people would be embarrassed to
create this thing and I don't think they
should be but I think they feel that way
whereas whoever we're talking about
these Chinese folks they're just like
yeah but we're just setting out to build
a great company right Supply demand what
is their demand for we can be Supply
versus uh you know we hired you know if
your company has 20% of people that wear
non-prescription glasses like it's
you're not going to make it in this game
because you just have too much uh you
know sort of like hipster in you that's
not actually going to focus on what the
market wants you're going to try to sell
them what they should want rather than
what they actually do want someone
tagged Us in this picture of a Thai
restaurant and it was called Thai near
me Tha food near me yeah Thai Thai food
near me where it was clearly someone was
just naming the restaurant uh you know
triaa locksmith in order to rank high on
Yelp yeah and that's that immigrant
hustle that I appreciate and I respect
and they actually made their branding
cute it was like a it a cute sign and it
was clearly a joke uh but that is
lacking I think in a lot of our circles
and this app real short they don't have
near me yeah it's tyon near me they
they've got they're just a they own a
store and they're like oh looks like
people buy a lot of Vapes looks like
we're in The Vape business you know what
I
mean and I appreciate that like man
these kids love this grap flavored smoke
right we're going to start selling more
of that uh even though I don't always
agree with it I appreciate the mentality
so you weren't there for this one but I
did an episode with Jess Ma I don't know
if you heard it heard it yet yeah I
started watching this morning I love
Jess ma do you know her besides like the
episode like had you met her because
she's friends well so Jess ma was um I I
was gonna ask you all about her but Jess
Ma I know her as like she was The
Prodigy so she was like on the cover of
magazines at the age of 19 or 20 for
starting indero and accounting soft she
was like the the person on the cover of
Inc before right the month before me was
Elizabeth
Holmes yeah so she was like the IT
person for a minute but then over the
last like six years she's went silent
which in my head that either means
you've done something bad or you're just
quietly killing it and you just don't
want to talk about it and it sounds like
the second one was definitely the answer
and Indo has been crushing it and she's
been taking the profits or money from
that and doing more things is that right
yeah pretty much exactly so she was like
all right IND is a good business it's
not going to be a monster business she
had like a crazy life experience where
her boyfriend died suddenly and then she
was like just kind of depressed didn't
want to even go into work and was just
like all right what do I want to do with
my life like you know reminder life is
short nothing is guaranteed but she
didn't say how big indero was though did
she It's Over N it's nine figures and
it's profitable is what she had said um
so it's over 100 million in revenue and
profitable so she was like all right I
don't want to run this company anymore
I'm hiring somebody to run that and I'm
going to do whatever's most interesting
to me and so her bets were kind of like
she wanted to like she's like well you
know like what am I like what if I
wasn't afraid of failure what would I go
do so she had a couple things in the
episode I think are going to get lost in
there but the big thing that I took away
that I went like basically after every
episode I send a voice memo to Ben about
like here's the three things that like
really like that that are my notes from
this episode dude I I I keep my notebook
right here but basically the thing I
wrote I was like she had like three or
four golden questions one of them was
what would I do if I wasn't afraid to
fail um the other one was uh what was
the other one wasn't it like what would
I do if I was a billionaire yeah if I
had you know if I had $500 million in
the bank what would I do with my time um
and she had another one which was How
Will I deal with being an absolute
beginner because if I'm going to go do
something new by definition I'm going to
be a beginner and suck at it and I know
I'm scared of that feeling and I know
that feeling is uncomfortable especially
now that I have a little bit of an ego
I've been on the cover of magazines
people think highly of me how will I how
will I deal with being at the bottom
again and just asking that sort of
acknowledges that and then it kind of
takes the power away from like that
insecurity so I thought she had some
like golden questions and one of them
was like she's like yeah like I was I
was like dude you're building these like
biot tech companies you're telling me
about these technology that I can barely
even understand do you even understand
these like is this your background are
you just a science genius and she was
like no like I was a c student in
biology like you know and now I have a
biology company that's valued over $100
million doll like there's some irony
there and I was like you know so what is
it are you just like fing it until you
make it or did you like get really good
really fast she's like well no like I
partnered with people who are experts
and I do the stuff that they're not
experts at like commercializing it she's
like but also I just started as a
beginner she's like I literally hired a
biology tutor and I started watching
podcast and TED talks and I would go
meet the people and I would ask them
like a thousand questions and I would go
do research after they answer those and
I would ask them 10 more questions after
that I would just keep doing that until
like I felt like I had a handle on
things it's amazing and I was like oh
well it's simple when you say it like
that and so similarly um I don't know
about you but every day I go on Twitter
and I see AI magic in my feed and AI is
the best magic trick like awesome cool
demo product that I've ever seen in my
life is just like an endless supply of
awesome cool 10-second demos I don't
know if those will all become big
companies but they're amazing demos and
you did a tutor thing and so I did a
tutor thing I was like oh yeah I should
just hire somebody who because I'm was
like either I'm gonna drop everything
that I'm doing and like go learn about
AI from as a beginner or I'm just going
to sit this one out because I don't know
it's just this fast moving thing that
the kids are doing and I I guess I'll
just kind of catch up later that doesn't
feel right either so I was like why
don't I do this I was like I put out a
tweet that was like well
if you're somebody who plays around with
all these tools knows how to use them I
will pay you $500 an hour I'll pay you
whatever 500 plus an hour to just sit
with me a couple times a week and just
show me just teach me about these tools
to save me the kind of like 10 hours of
fumbling around I would be doing myself
how many emails did you get I got like
over a hundred replies from like
interest like really interesting people
so it's gonna be hard to kind of pick I
might pick a couple people actually
instead of just one because there's so
many good ones and I might publish this
so I'm thinking about creating a side
Channel that's just like Sean's
playground my little YouTube channel
while I'll actually just publish the
call so that even if somebody's not
paying $500 an hour for this they can
just get the benefit from it um because
I I don't need to hold this close to my
vest or anything um but I think this is
great and I want to give myself a little
pat on the back but I really want to say
it out loud because there's probably a
lot of things like this like I know
you're taking a finance course right now
and that's like the same version that's
like the same thing like like don't be
afraid to go be a beginner you're
supposed to be S par business podcast
sold a business you know you're supposed
to be the guy who knows a bunch of stuff
and you you came out and you're like I
feel like an idiot when it comes to
finance like Corporate Finance I just
really don't know what the hell I'm
doing what's the best course in this
place in this thing I could take and
you're I think you spent like five grand
on a course right how's that going yeah
it's called um the 4day MBA with Keith
Cunningham um and yeah I'm trying to
learn how to do all this stuff it
coincidentally someone did a video some
billionaire guy did a video and he's
like don't get an NBA just go take this
course I know huge endorsement I like I
saw it when you said it I went to the
website website sucks and I was like
this sucks why did Sam do this and then
I heard that clip and I was like okay
that's now two people that said this is
awesome I will now go do this thing it's
a great course it's a great course and I
think I think my opinion how do I say
this without sounding like a chge douche
once I got a little bit of success I got
way less nervous about hiring people to
teach me how to do things um
additionally I mean we talked about a
ton my body Tutors or and hiring a
Fitness coach hiring coaches and things
like that kind of changed my perspective
of of the whole quote coaching industry
which I used to think was no
like teaching having people teach me how
to do stuff has kind of changed my life
a little bit um and this course is
awesome I have nothing to do with it I
posted that link and people thought that
I like I was like no I I just think it's
cool um it it's changed my life uh to be
honest like going back to school and
like learning and having people just
teach me things I think it's going to be
really smart for you to do it this way
I also think that if you promote it it
will uh pay for itself so that's always
fun um but I think you're gonna have a
life changing next two months if you
follow through with this yeah yeah yeah
I'm I'm already you know the the ROI is
is is baked in in into this because
because of it but I guess like I want to
say it because I wouldn't have thought
to do this unless just m she said she
just said that thing in passing like I
hired a biology tutor and I in my mind I
was like tutors are something that end
when you're 20 years old there is no
more tutoring after that and it's like
why why is that the case hold on there's
no rule about that um and there's
probably other people out there who kind
of could do something similar so anyways
I said it out loud mostly because if
you're the one% of people that hadn't
really thought about this but could
benefit from it like do it do you know
really what I want to do is what I
wanted to do was I wanted to take a like
one of those two-e MBA courses at
Columbia or Stanford or something like
that that was that's my goal for next
year to do it and I went and I looked at
like the list of topics that they're
going to cover and I was like I don't I
don't even know what those topics mean
so I got to go take this online one just
to prepare for this in-person one
because I was so embarrassed to to like
see this and I used to make fun of these
people that would put like Stanford uh
you know like twoe course one warning
though so I took a a similar like a
finance thing last year I think and it
was good there's nothing like it was a
good course there's nothing wrong with
the course what you did it in person uh
no it's an online online thing but I
intended it and I paid attention like I
was like if I'm doing this I'm going to
do it where did you do it at what's cool
it was on maven so it was a maven uh
Finance course and so it was a really
good course there was one thing that
I'll say out loud which is before you go
drop thousands of dollars because oh s
par said this course is great make sure
that like to me the way the analogy is
like these are all clothes on a hanger
but you need a hook to hang things on
and like if you don't have a hook the
hook would be like a business you're
currently running or like a a place you
can go apply these
learnings then I think they can be kind
of like fancy procrastination or just
like not worth the the time of the money
so you have to have enough either Battle
Scars or like a place to go apply these
that's actually going to be like
relevant for you otherwise it's very
easy to just like intellectually sit
there and be like yeah cool all right
well I hope I keep that in mind one day
when this becomes relevant like you're
better off like building the business
and then learning the things just in
time that you need to know when you need
to like when you need to know them
versus trying to learn everything in
advance and then be like now I'm
prepared to go do the supportive
business well the reason I'm doing it is
because when I was selling the hustle we
like this whole thing came at the end
called networking capital and I I was
like I just don't know what this means
and I optimized my business in one way
but then I I didn't know what this term
was and I there was many things that I
could have done differently that would
have helped and like I felt so
emasculated and stupid when these people
were talking to me about networking
capital and I'm like I just can't figure
this out when you're explaining it to me
I don't want to experience that pain
again and also I'm getting my balance
sheet and my income statement and cash
flow statements every month from my
accountant but I'm like I I don't know
if this is good you're just you
accountants typically tell you facts and
I'm like but I don't know how to
interpret it I need to know how to
interpret this to spot strengths and
weaknesses and I just remember when I
was selling my company of not I'm like
well I know I kind of know how to make
the money but I don't know what I don't
know how to optimize any of these
equations and I don't know what they
mean and I felt so stupid during that um
it was just so challenging to figure out
can I tell you one lesson I learned from
that thing that was probably one thing I
remember that I didn't know going in um
I just never even thought about which
was the course I think is called good
business bad business or something like
that and um one of the things it's
talking about when you differentiate
between a good and bad business
financially is your reinvestment Runway
so I don't know if you've ever heard
this term or thought about this but it's
essentially the idea that every business
let's say you know $100 comes in and you
get $20 out out of the bottom line right
you have $20 net profit what do you do
with that net profit so idiots like us
you I think you probably ran your
business same way I did I don't know it
just sits in the bank account I don't
even think about it really like uh it's
there I I hope one day to take this out
or maybe I'll I'll I'll use it to spend
if we need if we have some expense or
rainy day I don't know I just think I
won't even think about it and then you
uh start to realize that okay the best
business is they can either reinvest
into the business itself so that like
when a dollar profit comes out you can
reinvest it back to the top and get more
than another dollar out and so he broke
down like some of Warren Buffett's
businesses that had no reinvestment
potential so like basically profit comes
out and that's why Buffett would take it
to the headquarters the hold Co and just
say you the the best optimization he
could do was when he bought a business
he's like you're reinvesting Capital
poorly I'll take that money I'll
reinvest it in a whole different
business and you will be a little cash
cow but I'm not going to keep investing
back for more organic growth into this
business which in our case would be like
would be like um maybe like a course
business or maybe even this podcast like
this podcast like grows like mostly
organically we don't need to spend more
money in order to grow correct spending
more money is not going to create more
money out of this business the best
thing we can do is take the profits from
this bad business and invest it in a
better business that actually can do
that um and so you know that that was
and what he talks about is like every
business over time like you start out
being able to reinvest but you had a
certain point where a certain dollar
threshold where now you can't reinvest
more than that into this business at an
efficient rate so have to identify that
point and know that and then you could
judge the business based on that so
similarly um you know the best business
like constellation software or Burkshire
they're famous for basically taking
profits from one one bad business you
know bad defined as like it's a normal
cash C business but you're not investing
it back in that one you're investing it
to buy another one of those and you
invest that to buy another one of those
and that that's the whole point of this
book good profit or profit first um
Andrew recommended I read it this
weekend he recommended the same thing
was take money out of the business at
least and put it into a different bank
account and then redeploy it into the
your fast growing business if it if it
warrants it or if you have a business
that can take the reinvestment then you
know that that business is actually even
better than you than it looks on paper
because it has this extra capability
that most businesses don't have which is
what cold punches all of pretty beginner
for like anybody in like private Equity
or whatever that's not where we came
from right like we're basically like
dorks on the internet who then started
creating internet companies who then
like tried to get rich off internet
companies and now you know like we're
starting to wrap our heads around like a
lot of the like you know one 101 type of
concept which by the way I think it's
better to go that route I think it's
harder to start things from scratch and
then learn how to optimize eventually
versus you optimize you're a good
Optimizer but you don't know how to
start things from scratch like just
creating the widget that someone wants I
think is more challenging 100 per. plus
it makes me feel good that that's true
but like YC did the same thing he's like
it's going to be easier for me to take
badass engineers and teach them the
basics of fundraising and hiring and
firing than to take an NBA who knows
everything about fundraising hiring
firing but can't build and that was
like the core bet of YC was we don't
need to start these companies with NBAs
we could start these companies with
Engineers because we could it's easy to
teach them that it's impossible to teach
the other way yeah I I and I completely
agree with that and yeah it makes me
feel better that way so therefore it is
true in summary we're the best yeah we
bragged a lot in this episode maybe
we'll have another episode where we'll
just make fun of each other um no the
comments will do that for us here let me
move the microphone so you get a good
look uh here's my face here's my hair
here's my body you can hear my voice I I
I stutter sometimes what what whatever
you got go ahead hit us in the comments
um all right that's a
[Music]
pod